bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau 7,8
week-end votre magazine sorties et
loisirs
au sommaire ce week-end c'est la
treizième édition d'armes année une
exposition d'arts plastiques
peintres sculpteurs ou encore graveur
seront présents pendant deux jours
l'exposition est aussi caritative
puisque les dons seront reversés à
diverses causes
jusqu'au 6 décembre la salle
d'exposition à guyancourt se transforme
en décor de conte merveilleux
à cette occasion un conte a été
spécialement écrit et diverses activités
sont proposées
et comme chaque mois suivi là où la
directrice aude yvelines tourisme vous
donnera quelques idées sorties louis xiv
et versailles sont indissociables mais
avant que le pouvoir ne s'installe dans
les yvelines
la commune de versailles était un bourg
l'exposition un roi une ville louis de
versailles retrace leur histoire commune
sephora namani et patrick jacques de
dixmude la bibliothèque municipale de
versailles présente jusqu'au 16 janvier
l'exposition we de versailles dans le
cadre du tricentenaire de la mort du roi
soleil
elle retrace la vie de son monarque et
l'essor de la ville modelé par la seule
volonté royale louis xiv voulons à tout
prix quitter paris et affectionnons
versailles pour ces terrains de chasse
c'est un village de 400 ou 500 âmes à la
fin du règne versailles à la dimension
d'une ville de bochum d'une ville comme
bordeaux alors que ça n'est ni un port
ça n'est pas une ville qui est non plus
sur des voies de communication
importante ça n'est pas un noeud
commercial important
par conséquent cette ville devenue
importante les vraiment là vraiment été
par la volonté royale la cour s'installe
à versailles en 782 mais ce sera la
capitale jusqu'à la fin d'ancien régime
bibliothèque municipale archives
communales école des beaux arts de
versailles et musée lambinet conjuguent
leurs collections et offre au public des
pièces exceptionnelles comme l'acte de
naissance de louis xiv
des portraits d'époque des estampes
contemporaines et gravures d'origine
il s'agit du carrousel le louis xiv qui
fait référence à un événement qui est
lui en 762
pour le roi c'est une c'est la première
occasion de manifester en fait son
pouvoir retrouver puisque dans ce
carrousel sont invités à le suivre
derrière l'ensemble des princes de la
noblesse française c'est donc un
manifeste politique pour louis xiv qui
apparaît en empereur des romains l'
empire romain étant à l'époque la
légitimité absolue en termes politiques
et versailles et pourront même s'amuser
à contempler le très grand parcellaire
fidèle à la géographie de la ville à la
fin du dix septième siècle cartographie
sur laquelle on retrouve les trois
grandes avenues de versailles qui
convergent vers le château apologie du
pouvoir royal
vous en avez maintenant l'habitude
chaque semaine et libraires du pavé du
canal vous propose de découvrir un
nouvel ouvrage cette semaine leur choix
s'est porté sur une bande dessinée
comment faire fortune en juin 1940 de
laurent astier que ça viennent
d'horizons et fabien nury comment faire
fortune en juin 42 astier d'horizon et
nury donc comme son nom l'indiqué ça se
passe en juin 40
juste avant l'arrivée des allemands à
paris l'exode a déjà commencé et en
faisant un tour dans la banque de france
le responsable découvre que il a oublié
d'envoyer tout l'or au canada et qu'il
en reste 2 tonnes dans les coffres
évidemment ça tombe pas dans l'oreille
d'un sourd et à le convoyeur le
convoyeur de fonds qui est chargé
d'amener ce butin à bordeaux va
contacter des amis à lui et va se
constituer peu à peu une équipe dont on
peut les qualifier de bras cassés qui
vont prendre en chef en chasse par dont
ce fourgon on est en plein exode
évidemment la route entre paris et
bordeaux et remplis de voitures de gens
à pied de charette fin de tous ces gens
qui veulent absolument fuir avant que
l'armée allemande arrive
l'armée allemande en plus de sa survol
ces convois et irak ou à coup d'avion
donc c'est une sorte de road movie
de polar ils sont tous dans l'ensemble
pas très doué
on a un ancien un ancien la wehrmacht
qui est le pilote du camion qui suit le
fourgon on a un corps ce fanatique qui
ne veut absolument pas être assimilé à
tous ces français qui fuit qui fuient
les allemands on a une jeune femme qui
est experte pour manipuler les explosifs
et pour ouvrir les coffres enfin voilà
toute cette petite de toutes ces petites
troupes dans le camion qui suivent le
fourgon et à qui il arrive tout un tas
d'aventurés toutes plus loufoques les
unes que les autres
c'est plutôt réussi c'est l'adaptation
d'un roman de signac
voilà c'est assez drôle ça montre aussi
un petit peu comment dans l'est dans des
situations un peu extrême et d'urgence
il ya toujours des gens qui essayent de
s'en sortir et qui arrive plus ou moins
voilà c'est une bonne bd et ça a été
écrit par le scénariste de il était une
fois en france était également une série
de bandes dessinées sur la seconde
guerre mondiale ce week-end pendant deux
jours la ferme du mal et accueille la
13e édition d'armes année à cette
occasion cinquante deux artistes qu'ils
soient sculpteurs peintres ou encore
graveur explose au exposeront leurs
oeuvres
fernand romeo bonjour vous êtes
commissaire général d'arm année et
président du lion's club montigné les
trois villages qui organisent cette
exposition pourquoi rassembler autant
d'artistes au même endroit aujourd'hui
on sait de la 13e édition que nous
faisons donc après un arrêt de quelques
d'une année contre qui nous avons nous
sommes repartis cette année nous avons
52 artistes nous en avions 40 l'année
dernière c'était c'est effectivement
assemblée l'art avec un point critique
donc au niveau haut niveau
les fonds qui sont récoltées sont
entièrement reversés pour la maladie
d'alzheimer
le lundi cap et la maltraitance voilà et
pourquoi avoir choisi d'associer les
deux alors exposition d'art et caritatif
ça nous permet effectivement de de
mettre en valeur la les artistes les
artistes deux des trois villages mais ça
va au-delà des 3 villages puisque nous
avons des artistes qui viennent même au
delà de la france donc de bretagne et du
sud-ouest et j'espère l'année prochaine
à voir même des artistes qui viennent de
belgique et d'allemagne
l'argent récolté est ce sont des dons
comment ça se passe ce sont des dons
c'était effectivement un euro un nouveau
versé à leurs touches et pardon c'est un
euro reversé et ses dons sont
entièrement reversés pour ddd recherche
donc effectivement il convia nous
présenter un projet ce projet est validé
par le lions club et ensuite on suit
effectivement le tout tout tout ce qui a
été fait dans le land de l'argent qui a
été communiqué
cette année vous avez choisi la lutte
contre la maladie d'alzheimer le
handicap et la lutte contre la
maltraitance pourquoi ces trois choix
aujourd'hui on a on a ouvert ce qu'elle
vient effectivement au départ c'était
effectivement que la maladie d'alzheimer
on a étendu effectivement art ou
handicapées à la maltraitance selon des
projets qu'on nous présente et on s'est
dit effectivement pourquoi aller
effectivement que sur un domaine dont on
a essayé d'aller sur les trois domaines
sont donc dans ce cas là parmi les
artistes que vous présentez il y a un
style particulier où ce sont des coups
de coeur c'est des coups de coeur c'est
à dire qu'effectivement les artistes on
a effectivement à peu près 60%
d'artistes qui reviennent d'année en
année et nous avons cette année à peu
près une trentaine 30% des artistes de
nouveaux artistes dont d'ailleurs six
sculpteurs parce que l'année dernière
nous ils nous on était en manque de
sculpteur est donc cette année nous
avons six sculpteurs et qui seront là
donc équipe j'espère on permettre de de
nous ouvrir et d'aller d'aller encore
plus loin l'année prochaine
ce sont des techniques particulières si
vous avez cherché à montrer
toutes les techniques effectivement de
le dollar aussi bien des sculpteurs sur
du carton où il ya un site il ya des
dépeindre de toutes catégories c'est
franchement je vous invite à y
participer à venir nous voir vous verrez
vous ne serez pas déçus 13e édition est
ce qu'en général les dons sont
importants
l'année dernière par exemple nous avons
récoltées sur deux jours 4500 euros qui
ont été entièrement reversés cette année
avec 52 artistes on espère d'aller
beaucoup plus loin
donc on espère aller aux alentours de
5500 6000 euros nous je parle aussi nous
avons organisé une tombola depuis
l'année dernière donc une tombola où
effectivement le public peut venir et
choisir effectivement chaque chaque
chaque artiste expose une oeuvre qui
mourront tombola et chaque chaque chaque
personne peut choisir l'offre de son
sourire donc les le tirage sera fait le
dimanche soir lors de la remise des prix
d'ailleurs puisque nous à nous avons
organisé depuis quelques années depuis
plusieurs années d'ailleurs le prix du
public pour les artistes le prix du lion
ce club et le prix de la ville de
montigny
voilà et parmi ces cinq ans deux
artistes sont là quelques-uns que vous
vous appréciez particulièrement
absolument mais je le dirai pas là voilà
parce qu'effectivement ils sont tous
magnifiques mais effectivement on est on
est on a des coups de coeur pour tel
artiste ou tel artiste et on se bat
chaque année à les faire revenir et yves
ont été contre ouv des artistes qui nous
intéresse on les incite toute l'année à
parler de armani pour les emmener vers
nous c'est ce qui nous avons fait cette
année puisqu'il ya 30% de nouvelles de
vos artistes heures et vous les
découvrez comment alors c'est
chaque fois que nous sommes nous sommes
invités à des vernissages à droite et à
gauche les gens du lens club y
participent et dès que nous avons un
artiste qui nous intéresse on lan fait
alors on le lâche pas donc des fois
c'est un peu du harcèlement sans excuse
mais ça c'est payant au bout du compte
c'est payant pour les artistes associés
pour le son pour la bonne cause
merci cernant romeo des devenu en
plateau pour aller admirer les oeuvres
proposées ce week-end c'est donc samedi
et dimanche à la ferme du manet à
montigny le bretonneux
si c'est le théâtre qui vous intéressent
direction saint cyr l'école pour sa
deuxième édition le festival mort de
rire vous propose cinq spectacles il y a
une problématique
le rire c'est du 16 au 18 octobre
écoutez ophélie mur et la présidente de
l'association la divine comédie qui
organise le festival
elle était l'invitée de kiosques
mercredi soir pour y avoir prédit
participé plusieurs fois dans d'autres
communes on s'était dit que sur st cyr
ça manquait un peu et on voulait
développer un petit peu le côté culturel
et donner une image un petit peu
différente du théâtre pas rester dans le
côté classique ou tragédie
le théâtre c'est aussi plein plein de
choses c'est du rire c'est de la comédie
et donc on voulait partager ça avec
d'autres troupes de théâtre amateur pour
en savoir plus sur ces cinq spectacles
vous pouvez retrouver l'entretien
réalisé par sephora namani sur notre
site internet
on poursuit cette chute week-end avec
les idées sorties de civils aoun à la
directrice divine tourisme vous propose
des plusieurs activités et sorties pour
les petits et les grands
pendant les vacances de la toussaint
bonjour ce sont bientôt les vacances
scolaires mais aussi halloween
donc je vous propose d'aller pour
halloween au château de thoiry au
château de thoiry les 24 25 et 26
octobre prochain vous pourrez dans le
château découvrir tous les ancêtres de
la famille de lapanouse propriétaire du
château qui vont vous faire peur puisque
c'est halloween donc on va jouer avec
les fantômes et puis nous vous proposons
aussi d'aller à l'âge des petites bêtes
ou les petites bêtes
vous pourrez les découvrir
harper avec mais les parents sont aussi
de la partie parce que les 30 et 31
octobre prochains
nous vous proposons une soirée spéciale
pour eux pour les vacances scolaires
pourquoi ne pas aller à la ferme de
gally on vous propose des ateliers on
creuse des citrouilles l'animateur va
couper la tête de la citrouille vous
vous aller creuser avec les enfants à la
cuillère avec les mains et vous allez
pouvoir avoir une citrouille décoratifs
puisque vous allez en faire des yeux un
nez une bouche on pourrait la mettre en
déco de jardin mais aussi ramasser les
bonbons pour halloween
donc rendez vous du 23 au 31 octobre à
la ferme de gally pendant les vacances
scolaires nous vous proposons aussi des
sensations fortes c'est à la base de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines et
plus précisément la crau nike et c'est
le 31 octobre avec des peintures
fluorescents des vêtements fluorescentes
vous allez faire des voltiges des sauts
de tarzan dans la nuit et donc vous vous
reconnaîtrez uniquement avec vos
peintures donc rendez vous avec le
frisson à la base de loisirs de cinq ans
par le 31 octobre prochain
nous vous proposons d'aller au musée du
jouet à poissy et plus particulièrement
pour les enfants
vous pouvez participer aux ateliers du
film d'animation
emmenez vos objets favoris qui
figureront dans le film et c'est
l'association les flammèches qui
s'occupe de tout donc rendez vous le 22
octobre au musée du jouet à poissy pour
s'amuser à faire du cinéma c'est
halloween et nous allons jouer aux
apprentis sorciers et je vous apprentis
sorciers au château de rambouillet si ça
vous rappelle pas quelque chose
les petits bouts d'choux pourront aussi
y aller puisque c'est à partir de 3 ans
on vous fournit la cape la vague est le
chapeau et vous voilà apprentis sorciers
pour faire tout un tas d'épreuves dans
le château et gagné la possibilité
d'être un véritable sorcier tout ça donc
c'est au du 28 au 31 octobre au château
de rambouillet
des héros un méchante sorcière c'est
souvent la recette d'un conte pour
enfants depuis ce mercredi la salle
d'exposition à guyancourt s'est
transformé en paysage de compte et elle
invite petits et grands à entrer dans
son univers
notre invité en rien de maisons bonjour
vous êtes chargée des publics et de la
médiation à guyancourt est à l'origine
de cette exposition de quoi elle
s'inspire alors cette exposition est
parti en fait de plusieurs oeuvres
d'artistes d'artistes aux techniques
singulière très original et nous avons
souhaité partir de ses oeuvres pour les
transformer en personnage de conte donc
c'est à partir de 16h donc que c'est
écrit un conte et le propos de
l'exposition étant donc de découvrir ce
conte contes
c'est une oeuvre originale c'est pas
n'importe qui en est l'auteur ce que
c'est vous justement qu'est-ce qui vous
a donné envie de l'écrire et bien en
tant qu'homme je suis chargée des
publics et la médiation je fais donc de
la médiation de la transmission aussi
auprès de plusieurs publics notamment
des publics scolaires et c'était un défi
pour moi aussi de me lancer sur
l'écriture de ce conte ayant fait la
sélection avec mes collègues sur sur
cette exposition des oeuvres
le choix des artistes je connaissais
bien du coup tous ces artistes et
et voilà je me suis jeté à l'eau et et
voilà j'ai passé tout cet été à écrire
le compte du talent je n'aurais pas
cette prétention mais en tout cas
c'était un plaisir renouvelé d'autant
que j'ai pu être épaulé aussi sur 7 sur
ce compte avec des très belles
illustrations de julie dumont qui s'auto
figurent également dans le catalogue
comme tout le compte quand ça s'est
passé ça vous a pris beaucoup de temps à
écrire vous avez été retenu
oui oui bien sûr sur 7 sur ce compte
l'écriture n'a pas été faite toute seule
j'ai été épaulé non par julie dumont
l'illustratrice artistes et qui a du
coup fait les illustrations et brigitte
lurton et frédéric jacquemin deux
artistes présente dans l'exposition des
mondes merveilleux
voilà qui m'ont apporté leurs conseils
avisés leur soutien dans l'écriture du
compte
voilà ce qu'on y parle de quoi alors
c'est un conte qui s'inspire de tous ces
récits merveilleux ces contes de notre
enfance
et donc j'ai laissé une sorte de mélange
de tous et de tous ces personnages
archétypaux de ces lieux merveilleux que
l'on connaît et qu'on retrouve donc dans
l'exposition tels que la forêt le bois
des faits plus exactement la caverne de
l'ogre blanc le jardin étrange et puis
enfin le palais ensorcelée et est donc
on retrouve des personnages les héros
sont des enfants évidemment pour tous
ces enfants qui y voit là évidemment s
identifier tout le monde a été un enfant
normalement et donc ses enfants voyagent
dans ces mondes et traverse des périples
est évidemment toujours un parcours
initiatique comme en votre nom
non c'est dans ces comptes et pour nous
donner envie de venir ce que vous pouvez
lire cet extrait avec les alors je vais
essayer de livres alors commence
toujours un conte avec il était une fois
dans un pays très lointain un roi et une
reine qui vivait dans un palais de
marbre blanc
leurs trois filles jumelles était né à
l'aube d'un jour de noël de neige
elle avait la peau diaphane comme la
plus pure des porcelaines quant au roi
il allait toujours vêtu de blanc d'un
blanc aussi blanc que la pureté de ses
actions la reine avait pour soeur une
sorcière
celle ci habitait une sombre caverne de
l'autre côté des bois du royaume avec
l'ogre rouge son époux crainte mais
respectée elle usait de puissants
pouvoirs l'ogre rouge lui terrorisé tous
les villages alentours le jour de la
naissance des trois princesses la
sorcière aussi avait mis au monde trois
filles et mais elle avait là pour rouge
d'un rouge carmin aussi sombre que le
plus sombre derby un matin de brume lors
de l'une de ces chasses le roi tu à
l'ogre rouge de ses mains la tristesse
de la sorcière fut si profondes qu'elles
jura vengeance pour son époux point d
héritier à la couronne et de prince pour
les princesses et le temps passa et on
oublia la malédiction et on se réjouit
car le roi et la reine attendaient
désormais un enfant la veille du 16e
anniversaire des deux fratries
et comme il fut prédit le palais fut
pris du sortilège les jeunes princesses
se trouvait à prisonnières de leurs
draps translucide la reine et sa course
e changèrent temps tableau et
tapisseries qui en est alors la grande
galerie du palais le roi disparu et nul
ne peut dire ce qu'il était devenu
les années s'écoulèrent et personne
n'osa plus approcher du palais par
crainte de la malédiction
c'est une belle entrée en matière
d'introduction une fois que
l'interaction et fait comment se passe
la visite alors la visite peut se faire
évidemment du coup avec à l'aide de ceux
de ce catalogue donc aux figures le
compte les illustrations et des notices
biographiques avec des visuels des
oeuvres et des artistes
mais on peut évidemment s'imprégner tout
simplement de de 7,7 une de ces univers
singulier de ce conte s'immerger tout
simplement
il ya évidemment proposé aux sites comme
chaque exposition induit en cours un
parcours
je sois un livret jeu là ce sera un
parcours avec une carte des piliers les
enfants pourront voilà répondre à des
petites questions des devinettes pour
évidemment évoluer dans ces univers dans
cette exposition est aussi un petit coin
lecture qui peut permettre de se remet
de se remémorer l'histoire ou de
s'arrêter en l'instant oui en effet les
en fait les la scénographie a été faite
de telle sorte à ce qu'on ait un espace
central un espace lecture où figure en
fait des livres prêtés par la
médiathèque puisque c'est par la
médiathèque l'accès se fait pour entrer
dans la salle d'exposition donc des
livres qui reprennent donc des contes
traditionnels littéraires sont pour la
plupart des bandes dessinées aussi voilà
donc des créations originales mais ces
indépendants je dirais de notre compte
scénographiée mais dans cet espace on
peut retrouver par contre les
illustrations originales de julie dumont
voilà qui est surtout dans le catalogue
et autour de cette exposition il ya
plusieurs activités notamment ce samedi
à 11 heures une lecture de pratiquer
prada nous parler de l'ouvragé qu'elle
va présenter
alors en fait oui praliné gay-para et la
conteuse en résidence avec la ferme de
bel ébat à guyancourt et elle a donc
elle va proposer pour la première fois
le samedi demain dès 11h une création
personnelle en partant des oeuvres qui
se retrouve dans l'exposition
elle va donc raconter de très beaux
contes
des neuf continent donc des comptes du
monde mais au delà aussi c'est une
formidable conteuse
qui voit là j'en suis sûr vous captiver
toutes et tous donc l'idée c'est
toujours de développer l'imaginaire des
enfants
merci aurélien de maison ce jour ces
précisions si vous voulez découvrir les
contes merveilleux l'exposition est à
voir jusqu'au 6 décembre à la salle
d'exposition avec un accès par la
médiathèque jean rouch l'eau on compte
on continue ce cette chute week-end le
magazine de vos sorties et loisirs avec
une page cinéma cette semaine le grenier
à sel de trappes propose une
programmation spéciale pour les plus
jeunes d'entre nous le grenelle accorde
une attention particulière sur ce mois
d'octobre au film pour les jeunes
spectateurs
ils les auront droit à voir différents
programmes de courts métrages ou des
films plutôt porteur mais tous de
qualité pour les plus petits ils les
auront l'occasion de voir des deux
programmes de courts métrages le premier
temps les fables de monsieur renard où
ils retrouveront le personnage du renard
sur chacun des courts métrages ce qui
leur permettra de bien suivre les six
histoires dans la mesure où ce programme
s'adresse aux tout petits aux enfants à
partir de 3 ans on connaît le renard
comme un être rusé un être curieux un
être intelligent ce sera le cas dans ce
programme de courts métrages et ils
auront encore l'occasion de voir un
autre programme qui s'appelle des
petites casseroles ou là ce sont six
histoires toutes différentes et qui ont
comme point commun la différence je
pense notamment à un court métrage qui
est très beau qui a un court métrage
irlandais ou un petit oiseau doit
émigrer mais 1h07 la jolie at il fait ça
pour les plus grands notamment les
enfants entre 6 et 10 11 ans ils auront
l'occasion de re voir s'ils n'ont pas
encore découvert vice versa qui est donc
un film des studios pixar et d'ici ou là
il s'agit d'une petite fille qui doit
apprendre à contrôler faisait match où
il y aura également au tél 36 le règne
de deux qui est donc la suite du premier
hôtel transylvanie dans ce film là la
fille de dracula a eu un enfant avec un
humain
et ce petit garçon devra donc être
initié par son grand-père vampire à
l'art de devenir vampire
bien sûr tout ceci étant dans une
ambiance tout à fait détendu et très
drôle il suffit de faire se lance pas
peur et vous aurez aussi également
fantôme boy qui est un long métrage
sorti des studios français qui s'appelle
folimage où là c'est l'histoire d'un
petit garçon qui fait leo qui a 12 ans
et qui va être aidé d'un policier
annexes
ils vont ensemble essayer de sauver la
ville de new york donc c'est à la fois
un très beau film graphiquement et c'est
aussi une belle histoire policière donc
vous serez pris dans un récit
avec un rite 13ème temps voilà donc on
espère que les plus jeunes spectateurs
accompagnés de leurs parents seront
ravis de venir au mois d'octobre au
grenier à sel
merci ont conclu cette page cinéma avec
cette fois des sorties de la semaine vos
avis vos impressions vos déceptions
c'est au micro de camille lambert
heureusement qu'il avait pris sa caméra
après dix ans de repos on se laisse
embarquer oui complètement
les acteurs sensationnel gilles
lellouche mathieu amalric tout le monde
très enlevé très très dynamique super
c'est un film qui est trépidant n'a pas
le temps de s'endormir il ya de l'action
en permanence ses films remarquables que
je conseille à tout le monde et je
trouve que c'est très compliqué quoi ça
part dans tous les sens ça court dans
tous les sens et beaucoup de vent trop
long pas plausible bois c'est disons que
je m'attendais pas à un grand chaleur
mais bon voilà ça se regarde c'est
gentil on retrouve on retrouve le
comment dire le côté humoristique on
peut avoir
voilà super film je dirais pas que c'est
un de ses meilleurs mais il fait partie
des meilleurs
l'intrigué bien appuyé c'est tout c'est
toutes ces peurs lui tout c'est comme
chez d'habitude quoi il transcrit ça à
l'image c'est vraiment bien j'ai trouvé
ça un peu dans le style de match par une
peut-être un petit peu moins pervers
mais j'ai trouvé ça très très bien j'ai
beaucoup aimé ma stone joaquin phoenix
l'atmosphère
j'ai trouvé ça vraiment bien
autre rendez vous à noter à châteaufort
c'est dimanche 18 octobre la foire
médiévale 5,6 me elle revient pour sa
32e édition
au programme défilé en costumes danses
médiévales et ateliers pour les enfants
un spectacle à empreinte carbone zéro
c'est le pitch de rien ne se perd une
comédie absurde quiros il rassemble les
plus belles répliques de théâtre mais
qui aussi créer ses costumes avec des
emballages alimentaires c'est samedi 17
octobre à 18 heures à la ferme de bel
ébat pour un public à partir de 10 ans
on regarde un extrait bonsoir on s'est
lancé un défi faire un spectacle à
empreinte carbone zéro alors on récupère
on rafistole on recycle les cuillères en
plastique les pots de yaourts les
papiers journaux est également des
rideaux et acteurs et surtout les
auteurs vous êtes venus écouter une
histoire la route on vous servir le
meilleur du rocambolesque de l'amour du
sens du rire du suspense des petits
oiseaux et des jolis morts surtout des
jolis mots ceux qui ont été écrits par
les autres les écrivains les grossières
que tout cela c'est fini cachez ce sein
que je ne saurais voir être
la question le 7-8 week-end c'est
terminé je vous remercie de nous avoir
suivi la semaine prochaine c'est michael
almy d'euros qui vous proposera sorties
et loisirs
je vous souhaite un excellent week-end
et bonnes vacances de la toussaint